où
[Musique]
eddy bouvier vous êtes journaliste est
une habituée des points chauds de la
planète en février 2012 vous êtes restés
bloqués dans la ville assiégée de homs
en syrie vous êtes sorti après un
périple digne d'un blockbuster
d'ailleurs je m'étonne que personne n'ai
jamais songé à en faire un film en vous
la proposer oui j'ai eu plein de
propositions et j'avoue que en tant que
pigiste c'est difficile de dire non -
les rédactions de dix noms parfois et
donc c'était très dur de dire non mais
je pense que j'étais pas encore prête à
ça
j'étais pas encore prête à
j'ai mis du temps à raconter c'est
difficile de films il y en a eu 1 sur la
vie de marie calvin cette journaliste
iconique correspondant du sunday times
reconnaissable entre mille avec son
bandeau de pirate et ses tenues prada
elle a été tuées en syrie sous vos yeux
en même temps que votre confrère rémi
ochlick 28 ans à une nanoseconde près
vous y passez y est aussi c'est ça le
destin ou la chance
ce qui est fou c'est que ça tient
tellement peu de choses s'étaient ils
étaient bien plus compétents bien plus
courageux bien plus
fort que moi ils sont sortis vite parce
que c'est ce qu'il fallait faire - c
mais quelques secondes de réflexion à me
poser la question ne court pas très vite
donc je me suis posé la question de
savoir si je sors sans mon sac je
pourrais courir plus vite mais je ne
serai pas utile je suis là en tant que
journaliste donc il me faut mon matériel
du coup cessé quelques nanosecondes de
réflexion sur qu'est-ce que je prends
qu'est-ce que je ne prends pas qui vous
a sauvé la vie qui m'ont sauvé la vie
raconter la vie des civils donner de la
voix aux sans voix c'était leur drogue
c'est toujours la vôtre après le
calvaire que vous avez vécu en séries
ça l'est encore plus aujourd'hui je
crois que
cette blessure m'a
construite autant qu'elle m'a
qu'elle m'a détruite pendant très
longtemps et je me suis bâti aussi
dessus c'est leur force et leur talent
c'est leur courage
qui qui est aujourd'hui dans cette
cicatrice
que j'ai mis des années à cacher et
qu'aujourd'hui je ré accepte la
cicatrice kivu par la jambe alors on va
revenir sur cette odyssée vous est donc
resté neuf jours très exactement sous
les bombardements chaque heure est en
pire que la précédente je crois vous
n'avez jamais eu aussi peur de votre vie
commençons par le début nous sommes en
février 2012 vous avez 31 ans et vous
entré clandestinement en syrie pour le
compte du figaro avec six autres
confrères français et étrangers pour
couvrir cette guerre à huis clos
destination holmes quartier de baba amar
siège de la rébellion pilonnée par
l'armée de bachar el-assad et pour y
parvenir une seule voie d'accès au
tunnel d'évacuation d'eau un tunnel
france a d'ailleurs un tunnel français
la syrie a été sous mandat français au
début du siècle et du coup il ya ce
tunnel d'entrée dans d'en bas ben ammar
qui fait à peu près un mètre soixante
deux aux jeux c'est vraiment au pif sais
je sais que je me baisse - un petit peu
alors williams se baissent encore plus
et les chars williams daniel williams
daniel pardon mon confrère photographe
avec qui j'étais à ce moment là mon
sauveur
lui se baisse et en plus lui un sac de
photographes donc très lourd et c'est à
peu près 1 mètre de diamètre large
c'est long c'est trois kilomètres
seulement sait rien et c'est à la fois
énorme parce qu'on entend les
bombardements d'un côté de l'autre au
dessus on
faut pas le dire mais moi j'ai fumé
tout le long je déteste
l'enfermement j'avais peur on marche on
dit des bêtises on a rejoint
rémy
on est dans une espèce d'euphorie
qui ne s'arrêtera que le matin où les
bombardements vont commencer ce qui est
dingue c'est que on arrive dans ce
centre de presse de nuit il est minuit
1h du matin et c'est la première fois
que j'envoie un mail à mes parents dix
ans demain je vais faire la une je suis
avec william daniels photographe déjà
extrêmement talentueux et qui bossait
pour le new york times et rémi ochlick
qui bossait pour paris-match pour des
journaux prestigieux il ya marie calvin
dans la pièce d'à côté
journalistes américaines un argument
aussi glam que chevronnés dont qui a
jeté mon ordinateur sur le côté parce
que je la dérange aimé mais s'était elle
est loin de galles là on était à
l'endroit où il fallait qu'on soit et
j'étais en train de négocier que les
syriens le lendemain matin pour aller
visiter l'hôpital lorsqu'il faut dire
c'est que bachar el assad était
déterminé à ce que cette guerre à huis
clos ne soit pas documenté donc les
journalistes lors de ce conflit sont
devenus des cibles privilégiées des que
le régime a pu localiser la maison
transformée en centre de presse il l'a
bombardé
vous le dites à une nano seconde près
rémi ochlick et marie calvin sorte et
sont tués quasiment sur le point
d'impact sur le coup
et vous
et moi j'ai de la chance et moi j'ai de
la chance je suis encore dans la pièce
les bombes commencent à tomber ce matin
là en fait quelques heures après notre
arrivée et
[Musique]
je suis désolé ça m'émeut toujours
autant
et
les syriens commencent à dire il faut
sortir il faut y aller et moi donc j'ai
ces quelques secondes de nano secondes
je ne sais même pas de réflexion d'abord
quand les banques commencent à tomber
avant qu'on sorte
c'est là l'idée d'aller me cacher dans
la dans la salle de bain et comme quoi
on peut avoir des idées complètement à
la foire intelligente et bête parce que
je serais allé me cacher dans la salle
de bains j'aurais été protégé mais moi
j'avais peur des éclats de carrelage je
pensais que si jamais une bombe explosé
dans la pièce je pouvais blessé par les
éclats de carrelage et puis surtout je
voulais pas être seul je voulais être
avec eux sous l'être écrit mijoux
lettres et william je voulais être avec
eux et donc je les ai suivis dans cette
sortie qui est un peu désordonné
williams et d'encore dans la pièce paul
conroy également le photographe qui
travaillaient avec marie calvin rémy et
marie ont pu sortir avec d'autres
activistes
et puis
et puis le dernier boom la bombe tombe
est en faite le
on sent pas à la bombe c'est ça qui est
dingue on se sent on sent la poussière
dans la pièce on sent la déflagration
sans le choc j'ai été projeté en arrière
je pense que j'étais en train de me
rapprocher de la sa sortie et que j'ai
été projeté en arrière c'est pas très
bien compris comment je me suis retrouvé
sur la table qui étaient au milieu de la
pièce de l'autre côté tout à tous ces
déplacés
et les premiers réflexes que j'ai c'est
de 2,2 de voir si mes doigts mes orteils
si j'ai encore tout de me poser les
mains à côté du corps en me disant il
faut que je me lève
et là ma main se pose dans une tente
dans une flaque de juan chaud c'est mon
sens
donc là je me met à hurler ou les dames
c'est vraiment le premier réflexe le
pauvre et la cour tout de suite avait à
mes côtés il est là et
et on cherche rémy et
on va se cacher dans la salle de bain on
retrouve paul
qui est blessé également on retrouve les
activistes syriens qui sont à nos côtés
on se retrouve dans cette salle de bain
puis on se retrouve devant la porte a
essayé de sortir toujours porté par
william parce que je ne peux plus
marcher c'est fini alors effectivement à
ce moment là vous êtes
grièvement blessé les insurgés vous
exfiltre vers un appartement et puis
transformé en hôpital de campagne on
vous administre les premiers soins puis
en vous installe juste à côté avec vos
confrères ce qu'il faut bien se figurer
c'est que pendant tout ce temps les obus
pleuvent comme à gravelotte
d'ailleurs l'un des insurgés à cette
phrase extraordinaire à voter en fait
quelques jours après qu'on le
bombardement il ya des élections soit
disant en syrie et effectivement à
chaque fois qu'une bombe tombe ça les
fait rire et ils disent à voter il faut
dire que les habitants deux hommes ce
sont les belges de syrie apparemment
c'est les plus drôles et les plus fous
le jour du bombardement de la blessure
c'était un mercredi et c'est le jour des
fous c'est le jour on dit que les hommes
s'ils deviennent fous et donc dès ce
jour là
je ne sais pas d'où il puisé leurs
forces pour faire des blagues tout le
temps tout le temps c'était sans cesse
plus ou moins drôles en mai mais il y
avait une volonté indécis rien
que j'appelle papa noël
pas ce qui m'a mené des chocolats tout
le temps il me disait que les chocolats
ça calme les filles il faisait des
blagues tout le temps qu'ils étaient
toutes plus pourris les unes que les
autres mais il y avait ce besoin là ce
moment là des négociations s'engagent
avec le cicr et le croissant-rouge
syrien pour trouver le moyen de vous
expliquerai mais finalement vous refusez
est ce que vous n'avez pas de garanties
suffisantes c'est pas qu'on me refuse
c'est que c'est pas si clair que cela en
fait
alors je veux juste dire un truc c'est
que mon docteur j'ai deux docteurs dans
ma vie désolé mon généraliste
aujourd'hui mais j'ai deux docteurs
d'amour aujourd'hui donc et le docteur
mohamed ahmed qui m'a sauvé la jambe en
syrie et qui a essayé de faire ce qu'ils
pouvaient avec les moyens du bord
kim a mis toute la dose qu'ils avaient
pour toute la ville d'anticoagulants
parce que j'étais allongée qu'il fallait
éviter le lambine aboli graisseuse ouais
c'était le seul chirurgien il était
chirurgien militaire et c'est lui qui a
pratiqué les bons gestes donc il ya eu
voilà ça et quand il ya une tentative
d'exfiltration c'est lui qui m'a sauvée
en mettant de cloud à l'intérieur du
genou et qui a permis de
d'éviter que les eaux qui était
déplacé dans tous les sens tout se
casser en mille morceaux le tap sur la
fémorale et que je sois
comme on dit handicapé à vie pardon et
les négociations c'est qu'en fait le
jeudi soir les jambes du croissant-rouge
syrien et on savait déjà que le
croissant-rouge syrien a des liens avec
le régime donc c'était assez compliqué
de parler que c'est jean eric chevallier
ambassadeur de france pour la syrie
était revenu sur place essayer de
rentrer dans le quartier ils étaient
empêchés par le régime il n'y avait que
le croissant rouge qui avaient le droit
de rentrer donc pas de garantie sur dix
ans est garanti et le croissant rouge
qui au moment où certains partent il y
en a un et de les retrouver ensuite en
turquie et il m'a raconté que on avait
bien fait qui me dit si jamais vous
partez vous n'êtes pas
c'est sous votre responsabilité sous
votre responsabilité et vous n'êtes pas
à l'abri qu'on tombe dans un accident et
que vous mourriez sur le chemin donc
effectivement pas de garanties
suffisantes finalement voir des insurgés
tentent de vous et la cuvée par les
mêmes voies par lesquelles vous êtes
arrivé soit ce tunnel secret à cette
différence près qu'à ce moment là vous
ne marchez pas hélas l'histoire est
invraisemblable c'est la grande évasion
racontez moi c'est vraiment la gare en
mode cléopâtre ouais je suis sûr
dd
comme on dit les brancards brancard par
là
coach est scotché comme une muse rouler
au rouleau de scotch transparent le
scotch et d'écoles tout autour du corps
je suis en
en jogging entièrement
déchirer pour que ma jambe qui a
quadrillé de volume puisse rentrer et
en
robe longue pour essayer de me cacher un
petit peu et donc descendu là dedans la
tête en bas pour décembre par l'échelle
et après port car entre autres par un
trou d'homme par un trou d'homme est
porté à dos d'homme je racontais tout à
l'heure ce boyau
dans lequel les hommes vont vraiment
marché par un groupe i mais presque
pour me porter
les insurgés se relaient toutes les 30
mètres pour porter votre brancards et en
avance et williams est toujours
devant à porter le sac de rémy qu'on
avait réussi à récupérer et à essayer
d'avancer donc hyper chargé
et puis
bombardements et puis le bombardement
bombardements alors que vous arrivez
presque à la sortie du tunnel
là c'est le chaos total vos brancardier
finissent par vous déposé à terre parti
chercher des secours l'un aux une
kalachnikov sur le temps sur le torse
très utile mais il fait une prière et
vous laisse là avec william daniels dans
la fumée et le noir le plus absolu et en
nous disant je pense que c'est des armes
chimiques on n'y va
jamais été confrontée des armes
chimiques dont je ne sais pas très bien
effectivement ça pue mais est-ce que ça
pue l'humidité la poudre la poudre dans
l'humidité
effectivement les tirs commencent à
rentrer dans le tunnel
et on se pose la question de savoir si
par ricochet sur les quelques la
quarantaine de mètres
qui nous reste et ce qu'ils peuvent nous
atteindre
c'est le seul moment où william va me
lâcher c'est qu'en fait on entend une
moto au loin à homs faites du côté de
notre entrée
et il va aller essayer de récupérer
cette moto 2 de nous aider parce que je
ne pourrais pas franchir les 3 km il
peut pas me porter je peux pas marcher
donc c'est on est vraiment et puis
j'essaie de calage sur le sur le torse
et je ne sais pas quoi en faire
là c'est vraiment la dernière chance il
ya plus de lumière donc il part et c'est
vraiment le seul moment où il m'a ben
c'est pas qu'il m'abandonne c'est qu'il
est obligé d'aller chercher du secours
et c'est dur d'être tout seul dans ce
dans le noir dans le silence a parlé
balle de l'autre côté et ce bruit de
motos loin et je l'entends courir essayé
de courir dans le tunnel et heureusement
il arrive à trouver le chauffeur ils
reviennent me chercher mais juste avant
vous raconter une chose incroyable vous
dites je vais essayer de marcher en fait
vous oubliez en données que vous êtes
immergés ce marché ouais je vais marcher
vous essayez de vous lever de votre
brancard par réflexe spontanément et
enfin de vous rendez compte
qu'effectivement vous êtes ceci sonné et
mobilisés heureusement et comment en
effet c'est ce crash donc heureusement
willem a pris les clés de chez lui et il
ya encore les petits picots des clés
donc on devrait déferler scotch les uns
après les autres pour vous faire monter
sur la moto c'est ça et je vais marcher
trois mètres je sais même pas comment
j'ai fait pour marcher ses trois mètres
et william va monter avec moi l'arrière
de la moto on est tous les trois là
dessus et elle est tellement petit qu'en
fait je vais passer tout le retour à ma
jambe et est
et mal foutu donc je me tape le pied sur
le sur le côté ski permal
mais ça rajoute un autre endroit où j'ai
mal ça change un peu les idées et je me
cogne au dessus à la fin et ce qui est
drôle si on peut dire c'est que arrivé
au bout du tunnel je suis en culotte au
cs gomme pleine de bon on vous voit
surgir de terre c'est la stupéfaction ça
en culotte et chaussettes visage
ensanglanté et les syriens vont me
nettoyer le visage comme si de rien
n'était et me porter à dos d'homme dans
sur cette échelle et jusqu'à un pick up
qui va nous ramener à l'hôpital
parce que ben milieu d'une tempête de
pluie et de grêle et on arrive à
l'hôpital et je retrouve le docteur
mohammed hamed dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui me sort un cigare et qui est
l'aliment dix ans franchement tu vas
mourir ici et lui il trouve ça drôle je
ne passerai drôle du tout sur le coup et
c'est là qu'il opère pour me mettre
sévissent dans le pied dans le genou et
immo père alors
avec inler plus d'investissements et non
plus tout ce qu'il faut pour faire des
mélanges pour m'endormir et il m'endort
avec la bouteille de
de kétamine vous shootez la kétamine
c'est pas bien les décisions que l'on
administre chevaux après cette première
tentative avortée de grandes évasions
qui est effectivement failli tourner au
désastre les insurgés vous propose le
tout pour le tout sortir de holmes en
voiture le long d'un itinéraire secret
c'est l'option la plus risquée mais
c'est la seule possible c'est celle de
la dernière chance vous acceptez alors
que l'armée syrienne dans son ensemble
est à vos trousses c'est une opération à
haut risque pour le dire pudiquement
c'était quasi suicidaire c'était quasi
suicidaire mais un moment ce qui était
compliqué à
gérer c'était que on était à la fois
utile et pesante pour les rebelles
syriens à la fois utile parce qu'ils
espéraient que tant qu'on était à
l'intérieur le régime ne finirait pas le
boulot et ne tuerait pas l'ensemble de
la population qui restait encore parce
que quand on a raconté ce tunnel
effectivement de nombreux civils de
nombreux blessés ont fui par là
ce jour là ce soir là l'opération avait
été montée pas seulement pour nous mais
pour tous les derniers survivants du
quartier milan restait encore et en même
temps si jamais on mourrait entre leurs
mains c'était la fin du peu de soutien
qu'ils avaient de l'occident l'occident
ne les a jamais vraiment soutenu c'est à
cause de ça que la série dans cet état
aujourd'hui mais c'est à ce moment là
que se jouer quelque chose aussi pour
eux est celui dont je parlais tout à
l'heure mon papa noël un matin est
arrivé et m'a dit là on sort là on s'en
va on arrête on
on y va parce que ils sont tellement
hésité à chercher la bonne solution pour
toi pour eux pour le pays que personne
ne prend de décision on y va et donc il
nous a mis dans sa voiture où il y à mon
lui a mis un bonnet parce qu'avec un
bonnet il paraissait plus serré
apparemment moi on m'a mis on va
allonger à l'arrière j'ai été une femme
je ne parlais pas on voit les et on a
franchi des checkpoints des checkpoints
qui effectivement
appartenait à l'armée syrienne qui nous
recherchait qui avait mis notre tête à
prix et
il a payé ces gens
de sa poche pour nous sortir et là je me
suis retrouvé dans une maison la maison
des armes et des jeans oit
génois ces mêmes c'est mon autre maman
on s'est retrouvé dans cette maison où
cette femme ses enfants ont pris le
risque de nous cacher à remède est
reparti dans le tunnel chercher le sac
de rémy pour qu'on puisse revenir et
rapportées ces derniers effets
personnels à son à sa famille
et génois pendant ce temps mal avait
elle avait les cheveux mal avait le
visage m'a caressé le visage m'a parlé
m'a parlé longuement
et ça m'a fait un bien fou c'est fou
comme ces petits gestes m'ont
remis dedans mon humanité parce que
depuis la blessure on était dans la
survie
on était dans
dans un autre processus et là j'ai pu me
poser alors le dénouement effectivement
le connaît il est heureux grâce à ces
hommes et ces femmes qui ont pris de
gros risques pour vous sauver la vie et
auquel vous dédiez votre livre chambre
avec vue sur la guerre vous répétez à
bord a été traité vous et vos compagnons
d'infortuné comme des rois vous êtes
resté en contact avec toutes celles et
ceux qui vous ont aidé j'imagine
pratiquement entourée oui oui la mort de
marie coll vinh et de rémi ochlick et
l'incertitude autour du sort des
journées et étrangers
attirés finalement l'attention des
médias or le régime voulait que cette
guerre se fasse à huis clos finalement
elle s'est retrouvée sous les feux de
l'actualité grâce à vous un peu c'est à
la fois mon pire grâce ou à cause
meilleur oui c'est tout ce que j'avais
prévu de faire je l'ait pas fait mais en
même temps effectivement on a pu pendant
dix jours neuf jours le monde a des yeux
sur la syrie sur le massacre malgré tout
les reportages incroyable qu'avait fait
marrer colline juste avant notre arrivée
là on a enfin regarder ce qui se passait
en syrie et moi ce que j'aime le plus
dans ce livre si les dernières pages
parce que c'est la liste
des noms de gens qui sont morts pendant
ces dix jours c'est tous ces civils qui
ont perdu la vie pendant que nous on
essayait de sortir de là et à qui je
dédie le ivre au delà de tout ce qui m'a
sauvé mais c'est tout c'est oublier
parce que effectivement vous avez
conscience d'être une rescapée eddy
bouvier mais vous vous êtes tenus avec
ce livre à relativiser l'enfer que vous
avez vécu c'est une reconnaissance de
tas de ce livre mais moi je n'ai vécu
l'enfer que quelques jours les syriens
la ville depuis vivre cet enfer pardon
depuis plus de dix ans aujourd'hui ça
fait dix ans que leur pays est détruit
morceau par morceau que leurs vies sont
réduits en miettes que
que les réfugiés ne peuvent plus élevé
leurs enfants dans leur pays avec leurs
souvenirs avec les odeurs avec et qui
n'ont aucun espoir d'y retourner ou très
peu et que les rares qui sont retournés
ces derniers temps par l'opération de
réconciliation menée par les russes et
les syriens sont morts on dit sont
disparues dans des prisons du régime
c'est ces gens là que que je remercie à
chaque fois que je continue à travailler
sur la syrie à chaque fois que que je
pose le pied par terre c'est eux si
aujourd'hui tu peux me tenir comme ça
devant vous c'est eux
et je pense que ce qui me fait repartir
et ce qui me fait continuer à raconter
leur histoire c'est leur courage c'est
leur confiance c'est leur bienveillance
combien de temps vous at-il fallu pour
retourner le reportage après ce calvaire
géré marché le 6 juillet pour le mariage
de mes copains
quelques mois après 6 juillet 2012
quelques mois après ce qui m'est arrivé
est en octobre je repartais un reportage
en syrie pas tout de suite vos amis
combien de temps dans mon reportage en
syrie je suis reparti en syrie en
juillet 2013 pour certains jeunes
reporters le front c'est un baptême du
feu presque un passage à l'âge adulte
ces kits et une forme d'instruction ça a
été le cas aussi pour vous
non parce que ce baptême du feu je
l'avais déjà connus avant sur en syrie
ou ailleurs là c'est la peur dans ma
chair c'est encore autre chose et je
pense que c'est peut-être ce qui m'a
permis de
de plus mesuré la possibilité de mourir
que j'avais jusque là même si on est
conscient que le risque à chaque instant
je pense que on se dit toujours ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres le photographe
patrick cheval s'est longtemps demandé
ce qu'il allait chercher sur le front et
dans les zones de conflit la violence se
faire tuer il dit que la violence
finalement c'est une tentation une
attirance pour un homme d'image vous
êtes comme lui une junkie de la guerre
alors je vais citer rémi ochlick
qui disait et pour moi c'est vraiment la
phrase qui me représente le plus c'est
quand on est dans son canapé on n'a
qu'une envie c'est d'être là bas et
quand on est là bas on n'a qu'une envie
c'est d'être dans son canapé et c'est
vrai
après il faut savoir voilà pourquoi on
le fait jusqu où on va mais ces
questions il faut se les poser à chaque
instant j'imagine que couvrir une guerre
sans prendre de risques c'est une
équation impossible le courage disait
marie calvin c'est de ne pas avoir peur
d'avoir peur il faut avoir peur moi tant
que j'ai peur je pense que je vais bien
tant que j'ai peur je fais attention
à ce que je fais où je suis à comment je
le fais je n'ai je n'ai pas peur à paris
je peux sautiller jouer dire ce que je
veux haut et fort quand je suis sur le
terrain je fais attention on a des yeux
dans le dos on est on dort
à demi on fait attention en permanence
et c'est ça tant qu'on a peur on est
vivant plus qu'un métier est ce que vous
diriez et ce sera ma dernière question
est ce que vous direz que c'est une
manière de vivre
ce que vous faites
je suis pas ce serait prétentieux tout
cas c'est
forcément ça change la vie forcément ça
change la manière de vivre mais c'est
sans chalandon qui avait cette réflexion
très interne à east longtemps pour
libération et qui était un correspondant
de guerre incroyable et qui raconte au
retour pardon de sabra et chatila ce
massacre terribles pendant la guerre
civile au liban que sa petite fille
fait tomber sa glace et pleure
et qui lui dit mais en fait pourquoi tu
pleures tu es ridicule il ya des enfants
qui sont morts dans des conditions
tragiques dans ce camp comment tu peux
pleurer pour ça
et il faut oublier
l'horreur de ce qu'on a vécu et revenir
sains du normal c'est sa difficulté
qu'il faut toujours
sur lesquels il faut à laquelle il faut
faire attention
c'est ce passage d'un monde à l'autre
ouais
qui à la fois grisant et à la fois faut
savoir revenir à la normalité à notre
normalité ma vie elle est ici elle n'est
pas là bas la base c'est c'est le
quotidien des gens que je vais raconter
c'est pas ma vie merci merci
[Musique]